تشير التقديرات الى ان اكثر من 29 مليون
امريكي يعانون من اعراض مرض السكري يقول
الدكتور باترك ان احدى المضاعفات الاكثر
شيوعا هو تلف الاعصاب او الاعتلال العصبي
ولتجنب المضاعفات افضل شيء يمكنك القيام
به هو سيطرتك على مستويات السكر في الدم
يقول الدكتور باترك ان الرعايه المنزليه
مهمه جدا في الحفاظ على اقدام
صحيه نحن نقول للمرضى الذين انون من مرض
السكري وخصوصا اولئك الذين لديهم اعتلال
عصبي انهم يحتاجون الى الفحص والعنايه
باقدامهم بشكل يومي نحن نقول لهم بان
يقوموا بغسل الاقدام بالماء الدافئ عموما
وتجفيفها بعنايه بعد ذلك من المهم للشخص
الذي يعاني من اعتلال الاعصاب ان يرتدي
جوارب واحذيه مناسبه وتوخي الحذر عند
السير حافي القدمين واذا كنت ترى علامات
انهيار الجلد والتقرحات او الالتهابات فمن
المهم الذهاب للطبيب والحصول على العلاج
بسرعه
ومخاطر عدم الافصاح او عدم علاج الاعتلال
العصبي هو ما يزيد في خطوره تقرح القدمين
وانتشار الالتهابات التي يمكن ان تؤدي الى
اصابات اكثر خطوره او التي قد تهدد الحياه
او حتى قد تصل الى بتر اصابع القدم او
القدمين